it's the rocks birthday natural way I'm
Tom Geisel done a chronic rabble come
around last night like a vegetable and I
see with clarity like my name is Jerry
Tom but I've been telling you
accountants of equity
I'm Triple E given a pedigree convening
a pleasure my faculty between the work
that I'm doing are the moving furniture
seven headed uh
headed to a meeting this morning with a
Steve Ross my business partner on a
dolphin's real estate mogul all-around
great dude excited for it always enjoy
our time together actually trying to do
a better job
he yelled that maybe other days like why
don't you take me up on spending time
together
probably good idea spend time with
people that have professionally achieved
the things that you're trying to
accomplish especially by building the
biggest building instead of telling
other people to building stands
a great man I'm excited for our meeting
right now hon get I like that I'm gonna
get atomic laughing I'm gonna pull the
[ __ ] up
yeah just know my account all right
Steve how was the meeting meaning words
great any meeting with you is good and
what about piece of advice for a yacht
there's so many young entrepreneurs who
aspire to be a tenth of what you've
accomplished well what's your one or two
words of wisdom believe in yourself and
be pressure what you're doing and how
did Dolphins go do this year no
predictions and what about Michigan in
this tournament
well I still hope they have the heart
today showed and keep going so no I need
a prediction you're on the right I'm not
Regina but you know we get to a certain
point you make predictions you're quoted
all over the place
I just hope for the best I feel like we
see the world the same I zero idea how
this crosses over into what you've got
going on already but I just repeatedly
strategically decided you know what I'm
going to change my course even though
I've been going down a path I'm going to
get this in front of if she's interested
great demos fleshing out if not I'll
just move on my merry way but here's the
punchline
[Music]
thanks for respect hi you have a little
plug right like on Hornet yep probably
ok did you find it you want me to find
your book I'll read it here and I want
to remember that it came from you
like I spread it serious like that are
you for something weird no no I just
love jewel and I love you that's amazing
we'll see a few more oh this is how you
become a killer winner
I had a man at a wine tasting I came up
he's pouring that as the Marriott hot
Australian wine he starts pouring he
looks up he goes get the [ __ ] out of my
table
because your your the worst piece of
[ __ ] that has ever happened in the wine
business because you're selling this
wine way too low in price before I could
explain that the way wine library price
was we would look at the lowest prices
in the country and match them he's
blamed me because what would happen is
if there was five little stores in
Michigan or Orlando that had another
price we would match that but nobody
knew those stores and we were the big
guy so the other 15 big guys would have
this at $39.99 and I would be $34.99 and
I would get the blame for setting that
price even though if he went to wine
stretcher.com there was a ton of people
at 3499 he [ __ ] on me and I mean I've
never felt that way you know like when
get blood rush to your head yeah so that
happened three years later I get an
email from him I really love to be on
Wine Library
it'd be really important for I love the
chance to be on Wine Library TV three
people that knew about that story my
world were in my inbox okay we're like
ah I replied sure and had them on the
show then those three were waiting for
me to trick them get them in the episode
you never have any good no he didn't say
anything and I didn't because when
you're the bigger man you don't get to
Brad's either yeah yeah life is long
life is long yeah okay Garrett go go
don't I get any one thing you should do
in this company it's a little bit
slightly turned on what you just asked
but the absolute truth if you should get
to know every single person in this
company with every ounce of my soul I'm
telling you right now every one of your
lunches if you've got the time and
you're not on something should be in the
cafeteria and she's literally roll up
and be like yo hey it's everything
people people of the game skills are
commoditize my man the skills of like
taking good notes being organized being
on time being smart
they're stunningly commoditized the
relationships how'd you get here you
play the cross with somebody
relationships right you shake somebody's
hand you become friends with them you
understand what vaynermedia is going to
be
the media is going to be the company
that spits out the digital ninjas of the
future world somebody in this room right
now is literally the CEO of Nike right
now somebody in this office is the CEO
of Nike 17 years from now would been
really good if you said what's up okay
what the [ __ ] is that they want me and
my mean is I only got it I mean I got
five losses it means something okay yeah
yeah so I think continuation so 109 I
don't know how the time went so fast
today
flying let's do nominee all hand on
meaning it should be good 90 minutes of
Q&A Town Hall a lot of good client
meetings ruling but really internal
right now just super internal helicanus
ramp through the glass okay okay no
passion down hi everybody so religious
about doing what they do we just [ __ ]
make it like this is what right band is
less when you're at this point right
like what do you do
yep you know let's go
ah
[Applause]
let's go let's do it
let's do this take your salad let's go
you guys allowed to go good good
afternoon
vaynermedia how are you I'm really
excited about today's all hands-on I'm
really looking forward to the Q&A
session super excited about where we're
at I'm completely blown away by by pure
Wow and their culture and their company
and the people behind it so excited for
when they move here to Hudson Yards for
you guys to get to know them on a
personal level it's just a really good
relationship that's grilling I'm really
excited about the acceleration of some
of the work over I don't think I've been
more happy about like with the way the
company's moving over the last 45 to 60
days I we need to only the attention of
the end consumer I think it's
unbelievable even though I wrote an
ungodly check into snapchat years ago
how little I would care if they went out
of business tomorrow and Facebook and
anything else like just want to know
where the attention is good day
company-wide chat obviously have to edit
back carefully and strategically but
we've got a lot of points across so I'm
pretty good
hello senator some good I mean yes hello
it's a girl I think it's actually a
pretty good start I don't think we got
like we didn't get like the question
that everybody was scared of and we
answered but I think we definitely like
set a little bit of a foundation amazing
climbing can show that right and has a
client meeting Beast the Beast might be
a breakthrough account and size and
impact so feeding the Beast
you know trying to build an incredible
company some of you saw this clip your
people and you also let me know you're
not married is a balance between your
own personal brand and you know he
responsible for company and employees
and all that I run my company on this
video of an 800 person hundred thirty
million dollar a year business and that
takes up all my time
the garyvee thing is my side hustle
which is what I actually do you just
watched it the truth this is a side
hustle operating really operating all
right 60-second Club I can announce
right now I'm feeling it I'm going to go
hard next week next week I'm going to
give away some shadow sessions you've
been given a little a lot of t-shirts a
lot of sign books but we're we're going
super hard we're going super hard next
week 62nd club like and comment in the
first minute on my Instagram make sure
you hit up the notifications show them
that screen right now with the deal have
it turn them on so you get it and I'm
going to give away three next week
committing Tyler giving the calendar
three one-hour shadow sessions in New
York
you just follow me blow me in babban or
me Andy rock or something you'll just be
a fly on the wall learn some real [ __ ]
high-five spend a few spent 5-10 minutes
together yappin about your [ __ ] and
you'll just fly in the wall we'll find
the perfect hour for you can come and
you can come and hang a veiner for four
or five hours but you'll get one hour
with me and
so better get your [ __ ]
instrumentation up boys and girls
thinking a lot about which is forced
serendipity or serendipity right when I
hear that biggest piece of ice right
like what should I do here say hello to
people write your your one thing that
has been good in the feedback from
people four or five six months in is
when they take in that tact they've been
so surprised how warm somebody is when
they say hello that they're willing to
say hello back we just don't have enough
matches in the company
I'm also spending a lot of time watching
in the same way that I make decisions
about social and where the world's going
I do by watching the majority of the
reason we don't have a lot of structure
in place is I have a very good read on
you by letting me have a lot of room to
do you know what the funny holy
that's how you win this game you need to
be the ones like that's how at 50 and 80
the people that were here five six here
that's what they did
you're just a lot of hands just went up
right I know some of the hands that went
up and they haven't said hello randomly
to anybody yet let's go come on get in
here so I can passively see yeah
one shot baby so let's go no photographs
no so like you can't think about it you
got to do it like you can't have it both
ways you can't have us take care of it
and then complain about the way was
taken care of and you can't when I let
you completely have the freedom to do it
not do anything about it then you're
[ __ ] the planing you guys do like the
miners yeah I need to press yes Marley
I'm soul fighting I'm bringing it back
get your pencils ready we're back
you're ready
heading to Vancouver see ya one in the
morning just got to Vancouver to do
hotel I'm so real I'm gonna get a cup
and I'm a hot dang imma pull the [ __ ] up
yeah just come back Callahan's in my
account
yeah I'm gonna have my baby girl in my
dream house in my dream car no telling
where I'm hit the delicate me just long
usually the drive was white